it is no cliche that if you work for a
consulting firm you will likely create
lots of slides and so in the six years i
worked for the consulting firm mckinsey
i probably created really thousands of
powerpoint pages and so today's coffee
break here on my channel i want to share
some additional tips on exactly the
topic and specifically on the thing that
arguably is both the most important part
of slide writing but also the most
challenging part of slide writing in the
life of anyone working in professional
services and this is creating charts and
diagrams that first look professional
and then also communicate your message
in an effective and concise and to the
point way i'm very proud that this video
is sponsored by think say things that is
a plugin for powerpoint and excel that
is used by most of the large consulting
firms and i probably use it literally
every single day but more about them in
a moment so the plan for this video is
the following first i'm going to talk
about chart formatting so how to make
sure that your charts really look
professional second i'm going to talk
about chart selection one of the most
important things to get right is really
to choose the right chart type for your
data i'm going to do this with some
little exercises so it's going to be
very hands-on and then last but not
least i'm going to talk about some
typical errors that people employ when
they work with charts with data in
creating slides so without further ado
let's get into it let's talk about chart
formatting so let's look at this example
of a chart let's just look at the
formatting so how this looks what do you
think is this chart looking professional
should you make a chart that looks like
this and feel free to pause maybe for a
moment and potentially think about how
you could improve this
so take a couple of seconds if you like
and now i want to improve this chart
together with you and the first thing
that likely comes to mind is all these
colors in the chart so should you really
use that many different colors for all
these different bars here the general
idea is that there's nothing wrong with
using colors in your chart you should
just make sure that colors have a
meaning caller should convey a message
then you can use them you shouldn't just
use colors for the sake of making
everything colorful and so for this
chart i would recommend you to rather
use toned-down colors very basic colors
because i'd argue all these colors here
don't really help you to bring across
any message if at all it is distracting
from what you want to show and then
maybe you can set an accent a caller
accent on the latest year to stress that
this is the newest number here in the
time series the latest figure that you
maybe also want to focus on with your
chart the next thing that might come to
mind is all these lines that you see
here it just looks very crowded very
busy even though actually the numbers
that you're trying to show here are
quite basic and simple so probably the
first thing i want to take out are these
connector lines between the bars i'd
argue that don't really add any value at
all here in this chart and the same
thing is likely also true for all these
helper lines all these grid lines in the
background and here i'd argue what i
take out is also the y-axis to the side
in this example you already have all the
numbers on top of the bars why do you
need to show this additional axis take
it out and you will be very fine and now
let's also look at the x-axis because it
comes with a very bold dominant dark
black that really dominates the whole
picture so i'd say it's not really
helpful because of course you want
rather the numbers the bars to stand out
and not this very bold x-axis so let's
lighten it up a little bit now what i
would encourage you to add are rather
some arrows different errors some
elements that really help you to bring
out the message that you want to bring
out and of course what exactly that is
will depend on indeed the message that
you do want to communicate but maybe you
want to show how the revenues increased
from 2015 to 2021 maybe this is what you
would want to show and if this is indeed
the case why don't include a different
arrow that shows how the revenue
increased by 400 percent from
2015 to 2021 and then this will
potentially be a number that you could
also cite and refer to in the action
title so if you don't know what action
titles are also a very important part of
slide writing i will link another video
that i did on this very topic above here
so one key concept to have in mind here
is the idea of the data to ink ratio the
idea is that this ratio should be as
high as possible so ideally you're able
to show as much data as possible with as
little ink as possible and the
implication of this is that you should
just take out delete all the additional
filler lines helper lines background
lines axes and so on and so forth unless
of course they're really needed and
really add value to the message that you
want to bring across so always think
data drink ratio and this alone will
already improve your charts i promise
next let's talk about choosing the right
chart type for the data that you want to
visualize because this indeed is often
more complicated than it might look so
let's start with this very simple
exercise here you see different products
and how much revenue they contribute to
the total revenue of a company so the
sum of them all is hundred percent so
what chart type would you choose to
visualize this and again feel free to
take a couple of seconds maybe pause the
video to think about this indeed now
let's look at a couple of examples
because at least from my experience the
chart type that people will mention most
frequently in this situation is a pie
chart so we should surely use a pie
chart to visualize this right but here
what you directly see in this example is
that this pie chart looks quite messy
quite overcrowded the basic rule of
thumb is that whenever you have more
than about five elements to show pie
charts are quite difficult to work with
because the elements are just getting
too small to really display them in a
visually appealing way but then also at
least if you read the literature on that
just interpreting the area of an element
does not really seem to be too intuitive
to the human mind so is it really that
clear to you that for instance product
nine is twice the share twice the size
of product ten or product five is twice
the size of product nine so these
relative differences in area are not
that natural to grasp and to understand
and often bar charts like this as shown
here on the right might be a bit more of
an intuitive way of also really
comparing even relative numbers like
this and the key point that i want to
make here is that in the beginning of
visualizing data always make it an
effort of yours so thinking about what
the options might be and what really the
best choice of a chart might be for that
and of course some chart types just work
better for some specific types of data
than for others so here for instance a
couple of archetypes so component
comparison so relative comparison here
pie charts or stack column charts might
work quite well so for things of share
of percentage of and so on if it's more
about an absolute comparison then you
maybe want to go for the vertical bar
charts or the waterfall charts for time
series of course line charts or column
charts might work so if you really want
to show how a certain time series
develops over time then of course there
are distributions correlations and so on
and so forth i would actually encourage
you to print out this specific slide and
potentially keep it as a cheat sheet
next to your desk i will offer this
slide as a pdf for you to be downloaded
there's a link to that in the video
description feel free to just check it
out so now with that knowledge in mind
let's look at another example of a data
visualization so this is a slightly more
complicated data set you'll see
different numbers marketing spend unit
price volume sold for different products
that are here and the question is which
chart type would you choose to
communicate that the marketing spend
correlates with the unit price but not
with the volume what shard time would
you choose here and again take a break
pause a couple of seconds think about
this for yourself maybe feel free to
already download the sheet we talked
about a second ago for you to look at
and then decide which chart type you
want to pick and indeed the likely
several ways of how to visualize this
one example here would be these bubble
charts so let's say bubble charts are
always great when you have three number
dimensions that you want to have in one
chart so here the x-axis has the
marketing spend on the y-axis the unit
price and i think you can very well see
the correlation you could also insert a
trendline if you would want to really
make that more salient but then also you
see in the size of the bubbles that the
areas of these bubbles represent the
volume sold and here i think it's also
pretty clear that doesn't seem to be a
clear correlation between the volume
sold and the marketing mix you see large
bubbles both on the left and on the
right side of the spectrum so now if you
wonder how you really create charts like
this because maybe you struggled a
little bit with the built-in powerpoint
charts i can very much understand you
the build and powerpoint charts are
indeed often quite a hassle to work with
which is why a service like think cell
exists so things that is a plugin for
powerpoint and excel that really helps
you to create beautiful looking charts
and just improve your powerpoint
workflows in general think cell is the
sponsor of today's video and all the
charts you've seen so far and you will
see us in the next minutes are created
with things say things that is not just
any tool it is the de facto standard for
creating charts and powerpoint most of
the large consulting firms use it it's
also very popular in industry and a
business school it's a tool that i
myself literally use almost every single
day you just need to install things and
then it integrates with powerpoint as a
plugin you will see a little icon in the
ribbon to access all the functionality
or the formatting things that we did at
the beginning of this video this was all
things sale functionality if you create
charts with things that and send it to
someone without things say that person
can also open it and look at it and
what's even better is that they can also
edit the chart without having think cell
installed so if you would like to try it
out things that agree to an exclusive
offer just for the from learning
community so if you access things via
the link in the video description that i
will place there for you you get access
to an extended 60-day free trial the
trial is completely free no hidden cost
no auto subscription no credit card
required just the best opportunity for
you to try weather things that works
great for you as well and the best thing
is that i negotiated a second goodie for
you so if after the trial you are
interested to continue using think cell
you will now have access to a single
license so in the past you always needed
to purchase a minimum of five licenses
to use think say for you if you use the
link in the video description this is
not needed anymore you can just purchase
a single license and trust this alone
will make things much more affordable to
you and also if you are interested to
join consulting in the future getting
familiar with things that we are the
extended free trial is for sure good
idea because chances are high that your
consulting firm will use things then as
well and surely it's a great idea to be
prepared so with all of this in mind
let's look at a third example of
choosing the right chart type so here
you have the example of a pna so profit
and loss statement of a company one of
the three key financial statements that
companies need to produce so let's
imagine you would want to visualize this
p l in a chart which one would you like
to choose and here again pause a moment
think about this maybe this is less
trivial less clear because indeed one
chart type that is extensively used in
consulting that is very very suited also
to visualize things like p else are the
waterfall charts so what we have here is
the data entry window of things that you
can see that already copied in all the
numbers the letter e stands for equals
and things that here can help you to
automatically calculate totals and
subtotals so no need to do this manually
anymore things will do the calculations
for you and provide you with the correct
results and also notice how you can
stack waterfall segments just by writing
the numbers under each other here in the
column for the personal cost and indeed
this is the result this is what the
waterfall chart will look like but now
you're already seeing a problem and this
is because all the numbers are entered
in million right so the numbers are
quite long this is surely not how you
would want them to look like so what do
you do now do you need to know go back
to the data entry mask and change all
the numbers or the excel by the way you
can also integrate things that in excel
to automatically update charts like this
well of course not because one of the
many very handy thing cell
functionalities is that just with a
couple of clicks you can really
transpose all these numbers and for
instance round them to millions as i'm
doing right here just with a couple of
clicks you have really the chart now
exactly the way that you want it to look
so now last but not least let's look at
some typical errors that people do when
they create charts and i think one of
the main problems is if you just use the
built in powerpoint charts so not use
the think cell charts then often these
charts come already pre-configured with
some problems so all the charts you see
right here are design templates that are
suggested layouts suggest the designs
within powerpoint so here you see charts
with these glossy effects with shadows
with 3d effects with these weird shaded
backgrounds so now we could look into
this in much more detail but i hope that
you agree just at the first look and
feel that these charts don't really look
professional so let's just look here at
this profitability surface chart which
again is one of the suggested templates
by powerpoint how this looks i mean it's
virtually impossible to get really any
insight any message out of this chart at
all just to distill any number out of it
at all so you should really avoid all
layouts like this i think we know
extensively already talked about
formatting i want to leave you with one
last piece of advice because this is
something that i often also see done
wrongly and this is in general trying to
avoid having too many different charts
too many different messages on one slide
there is the basic rule of thumb which
says one message per slide really try to
stick to one message per slide this
usually makes the whole storytelling
much easier helps you to create more to
the point nicely formatted nicely layout
pages several charts on one page can be
okay but only if you really need all
these charts next to each other to
really get the one message out that you
want to share otherwise rather split it
up and show them on different pages so
now after i've shared all this advice of
course i'd love to hear from you do you
have any tips and suggestions for
working with data working with charts
and powerpoint that you like to share
please just leave a comment in the
comment section trust us would be
insightful to all the other people
reading the comments as well if you took
any value out of this video at all
please hit the like button for the
youtube algorithm and also subscribe and
turn on the notification bell to stay up
to date on all my content was a big
thanks to all the members of from
learning for supporting the channel and
a big shout out again to thinksail for
supporting this channel by sponsoring
this video if you'd like to try out
things that yourself you can access it
via the link in the video description
you will get access to an extended
60-day free trial and after the trial
you have access to single licenses which
is not the standard offering of things
sale so try out things sell and see for
yourself but that has that much of an
impact on how you create slides as much
as for sure has for me thanks to all of
you my name is heinrich i release weekly
videos here on firm learning looking
forward to talk to you again next week
until then all the best to you and bye
bye